it's a new year
can we talk about the Sabrina
Valentine's Day episode and just just
tell us although - secret um yes okay
what can i I'm so bad at spoilers I'm
the worst person ask these kind of
questions it's gonna be there's gonna be
a lot of sensual love yeah that's that's
what I can say the best visual love
reminds me of the the witch orgy is that
on that heat that's whoever gun that's
your guy why would you do that because
she and her [ __ ] sisters are your seat
and then how are things gonna change
next season now that you found out that
your father Blackwood's daughter um
you'll see prudence kind of grow into
her own and kind of establish more of
her identity and truly feel confident in
herself so I think as an orphan like not
having your father or your father being
there not if not oak like accepting you
your whole life
it's a lot to process but it I believe
especially for women that it makes us
stronger the things that we go it does
not weaken us so yeah you'll see your
kind of girl into herself I really want
to be queen to you of course I do one
thing that we love about you being on
chilling Adventures of Sabrina is one
this thing that your hair so can you
tell us the secret behind keeping that
short beautiful dude um I am learning so
much about my hair like since I cut it I
use it's a it's a 10 miracle that
miracle leave-in that's the most amazing
thing for my life yes yes like I use my
hair so like the most soft that I've
ever felt my hair ever one thing I love
about you is you're so different from
your character she's sweet and it's like
you are just on on that show you are
just such a man as I have to say that I
mean how do you separate the two
characters
like I let prudence be her own and like
my thing is I think everybody has method
to madness nobody's even for the sake of
being evil and so I try to understand
her on a deeper level
[Music]